oh we're British I hope they show
gameplay the [ __ ] is gonzo doing in
there
I'm pretty sure this is an advertisement
for boots apparently when you punch them
on urine comes out of your face why are
they gonna bring a fire yeah that's what
I was wondering who fights in a ring of
fire look that guy never attachment for
Axe body spray
it's Axe body spray spraying off of them
every time they hit each other this
whole game in slow motion oh I've done
that to a homeless guy is he wearing the
guy's head now that's hard ass
finally a video game about people with
red eyes Killzone 3 another trailer with
no gameplay oh but at least they showed
us a picture of the system
[Music]